[Music]
Prologue This
may seem similar to what happened in the past, but the
times ahead
are very different from those we've experienced with disabilities. How do we know that?
Because it's always been that way.
[Music]  ] I was
painfully reminded that the most important thing that surprised me in my nearly 50 years of global macroeconomic investing was because it had never happened before because of my disability.  This
painful surprise led me to
study similar situations in the past 500 years of history,
and I
found that it had happened many times before, in empires like the
Netherlands, the American
Empire,
and the
United States.
And whenever this happened, it
was a sign of change in one part of the world.
[Music]
This research has provided us with valuable lessons
that I will further refine and share with you.  For a
more comprehensive explanatory view,
read my book, The Changing World Order.I
begin with the story that led me to this position: how I
learned to predict the future by studying the past.
This is about
[Music]
In 1971, when I was working as a clerk at the New York Stock Exchange, the United States ran
out of money and defaulted on its debts.
That's right, the United States ran out of money.
How did it happen?  Well, in those days it was only
used for transactions between countries, and
paper money like the dollar was like a check in a checkbook.The
value of arson was that it could be exchanged for gold, the money of the gods.  At
that time, the United States was spending so
much more than it was receiving revenue that it was printing more gold than the banks that could
exchange checks had.  The amount of gold in the United States' holdings
decreased as the dollar amount was converted into cash. It soon became clear that the United States would not be able to
keep its promise on all the notes it had issued, and
those holding dollar bills had to hurry before they ran out of gold.
Recognizing that the United States was essentially running out of money, on the
evening of Sunday, August 5, President Nixon
went on television and announced that the United States had promised to make people exchange their money for money.  They made a
statement to the world that the United States was in default, and of course they didn't
tell the world
exactly what it said. They
made it more relevant without revealing that the United States was in default. The
strength of the country's currency was  It's also based on the strength of a country's economy,
and America's economy
is by far the strongest in the world, so I've directed the Secretary of the Treasury to
take the necessary actions to protect the dollar from speculators.
We have directed the Secretary of the Treasury to temporarily suspend the exchange of dollars with gold or other reserves unless the amount and circumstances are in the best interests of currency stability and the national interests of the United States.  I watched the press conference in awe as I realized that what I had understood was coming to an end.
What a
crisis! I
anticipated that the stock market would plummet the next day, so I
made preparations for the stock exchange early.  When the
opening bell rang, there was chaos,
but it wasn't the type of chaos I expected. The
market went up, by a lot,
up about 25%. That's the most surprising thing I've ever seen.
Because the United States had never experienced a currency devaluation, and I looked
back in history, and
I found that exactly the same thing happened in 1933, and it had exactly the same effect.
Back then, the U.S. dollar bill was gold standard.  Money was
becoming scarce because they were consuming more paper checks than they were exchanging for gold,
and President Roosevelt announced on the radio that he was
reneging on the country's promise to exchange for the money it took.  At
that time I issued a proclamation providing for a national bank holiday.
This
was the first step in the restructuring of the financial and economic structure by the government. The
second step was a quick few patriotic calls by members last Thursday.  The
law passed
confirms my declaration and expands my powers to
extend the holiday and
gradually lift the ban on the holiday, taking into account the time requirements.This
law also provides for the program  In
both cases, banning money and hitting allowed the
U.S. to continue to spend
more than it was willing to spend.  All you do is
print money, and
as the number of dollars increases without increasing the wealth of the country, the value of the dollar decreases
without seeing a corresponding increase in productivity.As these new
dollars enter the market,
people...
As I studied more history, I discovered that the
exact same thing had happened over and over again before.  Since the
beginning of history, governments have been
spending more money at tax time, and when things get bad, they run out of currency and they
need
more money, so they print more money.
This includes stocks and
goods.
[Music]
That's when I first learned the following principle:
Central banks print a lot of money to avert a crisis.  When you
buy stocks and gold products,
their value goes up, which makes the
value of paper money go down.
This kind of money printing was done in 2008 to
ease the mortgage debt crisis, and it will continue to be printed
in 2020.  This is
being done to alleviate the economic crisis caused by the pandemic, and will
almost certainly be done in the future,
so keep this principle in mind.
[Music]
These experiences have taught me another principle.
To understand what happens to you, you need to understand what happened to Kurt.
This principle helped
me understand how the bubble of the Roaring Twenties
turned into the Great Depression of the 1930s.  So I
ended up doing some research, and this
gave me some super [ __ ] that would allow me to predict and profit from the 2007 bubble when it turned into the 2008 bubble burst.  The
almost instinctive urge to look to the past for similar situations to learn how to handle them better in the future brought
me
changes in places that had not
happened in my lifetime over the past few years.
Three big things
inspired me to do this research: First, countries around the world don't
have enough money to pay their debts, so they
lowered interest rates to 0%. So
central banks are forced to pay their debts.
Second, the gap between wealth and leisure
has widened, leading to a major internal conflict between the
left, which wants to redistribute wealth, and the right, which wants to protect the winter season.  This has
manifested itself in political populism and polarization.
Third, there has been an increase in external conflicts between rising powers and leading powers, such as what is currently occurring between China and the United
States.
So I looked back.  We've found that all of these
things have happened simultaneously before, many times and almost always leading to changes in the domestic and global order. The last time this sequence happened was from 1930 to
1945.  You may be wondering what exactly we mean by ``a
system of governance for people who correspond to each other, a local order within a country,
usually enshrined in a constitution,'' and a system of government for people who correspond to each other.
There is a world order that applies between countries and countries, and this is usually set out in treaties.
Anarchy without a country
changes at a different time from the world order, whether it is within
countries or between countries.  Order usually
changes after a war, which
is a domestic civil war or an international war between countries.A war occurs when a
scientifically new force defeats a weakened old order.For
example, the domestic order in the United States is the United States.  It is
stipulated in the constitution enacted in 1789 after the War of Independence,
and after the Civil War,
that constitution is still in effect to this day.With the
Russian Revolution of 1917, Russia
eliminated the old order and established a new system.  It
established order. It was a relatively bloodless
revolution that ended in 1991.
China's current domestic order
began in 1949, when China won the war without the Communist Party. Did you
understand? The
world is now  The order, commonly referred to as the American World Order,
was formed after the Allied victory in World War II,
when the United States emerged as the dominant power, controlling global governance and
currency.  Agreements and treaties were established about how the system would work.
In 1944, the new world monetary system was
established in the Bretton Woods Agreement,
establishing the dollar as the world's leading reserve currency.
Having a reserve currency
is a key factor in becoming the richest and most powerful empire. Once a
new dominant power and monetary system is established
, a new world order is established.
These changes occur because of a timeless, universal cycle that I call the Big
Cycle.I'll start with a brief overview, and for the first time, I'll
give you a more complete version, and
if you're interested in learning more, you can read my book.  Introducing the
10 most powerful empires over the past 500 years,
and our study of the last three reserve currencies,
which
led us to the battle history of the following countries: the Dutch Empire and the British Empire, and the
British Empire and the Pound Sterling.  The Holy Waters of the
American Empire and the Rise and Early Processing of the Dollar, and the
Decline and Rise of the Chinese Empire and its Flowers,
as well as the Holy
Waters of Spain, Germany, France, Russia, Japan, Russia, the Ottoman Empire, and
China. Those important conflicts are compared together in this chart.
To repeat the pattern, we studied Chinese dynasties and their floral patterns going back 600 years.Seeing
these numbers all at once can be confusing,
so we looked at the four most important countries:
Netherlands, UK, USA and China.  Pay attention. You
'll notice a pattern right away.
So let's simplify the phone a little bit. As you can see,
this pattern lasts about 250 years and
occurs in overlapping cycles, with
transition periods of 10 to 20 years between the cycles.
Generally, these transition periods are periods of great conflict,
because major powers
don't decline without a fight.So how did the Sadako powers
compare?
In this study, we used eight criteria.  The
overall strength of a country is the sum of everything
divided by the average.The criteria
are:Education
Originality and technological developmentCompetitiveness
in world marketsProportion of
economic output or world tradeMilitary
strengthCapital
markets  the strength of its financial centers, and the
strength of its currency as a reserve currency.These
forces are measurable, so we can look at
how strong each country is now, how strong it was in the past,
whether it's trending upward or toward decline.
By studying the rise and fall of many countries, we can
learn how common cycles occur, and the rise and fall of a
typical empire, since rapid change can be confusing.  We clarify this by
focusing on the patterns of cause and effect relationships that drive decline and decline.As we can see,
better education generally leads to increased power and
technological development, followed by the establishment of the
currency as a reserve currency.  You
will also see that these forces decline in a similar order and move toward each other's decline.
Now we can describe the general sequence of events occurring within the countries that produce these rises and declines.  Let's take a look at
what happened, in a
nutshell: A big
cycle typically
begins after a major conflict, often a war, where a new great power and a new
world order are established,
because no one wants to challenge this power.  Peace and prosperity
generally follow.As people become accustomed to this peace and prosperity and
become increasingly dependent on its continuation, they
begin to borrow money to continue, which eventually
leads to financial bubbles.  As the proportion of the empire's trade
grows, most
transactions come to be carried out in that currency, and
this
leads to even more currency,
while at the same time this increased prosperity creates an
imbalance in wealth.  This generally widens the
gap between the wealth of the Yunfu haves, the poor have-nots, and the have-nots.Eventually, the
PU bubble bursts, money is
printed, and internal conflicts between the rich and the poor
increase.  This
leads to some form of revolution to redistribute wealth,
which may occur peacefully or through internal conflict.
While the empire struggles with internal conflicts, external
rivals emerge.  Its power declines relative to its own power. When a
new power
becomes powerful enough to compete with the disintegrating dominant power within the country, conflicts,
most commonly wars, occur.
These internal conflicts and wars with other countries.  This
creates new winners and losers,
and the winners work together to create a new world order, and the
cycle begins all over again. In
retrospect, these causal relationships
drive the cycle of rise and fall of nations.  It
turns out that it can be traced all the way back to the Roman Empire, just as this story
blends with other stories to
create the epic 500 years that are our collective history.  I
realized how intertwined the stories of each of these cycles are, before, during, and after,
and like the human life cycle, no
two cycles are exactly alike, but
most do go through...
This cycle is driven by a logical cause-and-effect relationship that progresses through stages from birth to strength and maturity, and from weakness to inevitable decline, as the
average human lifespan is 80 years.
Age
can be a good indicator of future life expectancy, but a
better indicator is health.  It
can also be applied to:
observing indicators of power transitions
can tell us where a country is in the cycle, and this can
help predict the next stage that is likely to follow.
So let's talk more about the Big Cycle. Let's take the
next 20 minutes to walk you through the last 500 years of history and
explain similar patterns in the Dutch, British, American, and Chinese empires.
500 Years of the Big Cycle
We break down the cycle into three phases:
Rise,
Peak, and Decline. Rise The success of a rising new order, both internal and external,
typically
begins with a strong revolutionary leader who does four things:  They
gain power by gaining more support than their adversaries.Second, they
consolidate their power by displacing, weakening, or eliminating their adversaries so that they do not get in their way.Third.
Establish postures and systems that will allow the country to function well.Fourth,
choose successors well or
create a system that makes it possible.A
great empire requires many great leaders over several generations.
After the
battle is won at this stage, there is generally a
period of peace and growing prosperity, because the
leadership is so clearly dominant and
has widespread support that no one is willing to challenge it.
A country's leaders must
build good systems to increase the country's wealth and power.First and
foremost,
good leaders need to spend on: A
good education
This is just to teach.  knowledge and skills, as well as
solid character, civility, and work ethics,
which are generally taught in home schools
and religious high school.This is the common goal of
respecting rules and laws,
maintaining order in society, and
reducing mismanagement.  They can unite around a purpose and work
together successfully,
moving from producing basic products to innovating and inventing new technologies.For
example, the Dutch
successfully overthrew the Habsburg Empire.  educated,
became highly inventive and produced a quarter of the world's major inventions,
the most important of which was the invention of the
ship, which allowed people to travel the world to collect wealth,
and  Capitalism as
we know it today was invented to finance these voyages,
and like all major empires, the Dutch
strengthened their thinking by embracing the world's best thinking.  As a result, people in particular
became more productive and more
competitive in the world market,
which led to
growth in economic output and an
increase in the Dutch share of world trade, and an increase in economic output and
world trade between the United States and China.  You
can see that this same thing is happening now, with roughly equal proportions:
As countries trade more globally, they need to protect their trade routes and foreign interests.  A
superior military force will be deployed. If successful, the
cycle
will lead to strong income growth, which will fund investments in education, infrastructure, research and development,
and the ability to create or receive wealth.
In all these cases, the most
successful empires use a capitalist approach to
developing highly productive entrepreneurs.By the Chinese
Communist Party
Even China, where it is run, uses a form of this capitalist approach.
[Music]
Deng Xiaoping responds to a question by saying, "Whether it's a
white cat or a black cat, a cat that catches mice
is a good cat, and it doesn't make you rich."  And
to do this well, we
need to foster capital markets, and the most important one
is the loan and stock market, which allows people to
turn their savings into investments to fund inventions and developments, which is
great.  We
can share in the successes of those who make things happen. The
Netherlands created the first publicly traded company, the
Dutch East India Company,
and the first stock market to fund it.
This was a system that generated enormous wealth and power.
As a natural progression, the largest empire would develop the world
's major financial center to attract and redistribute the world's capital.Amsterdam was the
financial center of the world at a time when the Netherlands was preeminent.
When Britain was at the top, it
was London, and now it's New York, and China is
rapidly developing its financial centers, and
the most important thing is that the government and the military
work together, and
in the Netherlands they just worked well together.
Rather, the three were one in the same: the
Dutch East India Company was granted a monopoly trading bloc by the government, and
had its own officially sanctioned military to reach global markets to create and steal wealth.
Britain followed with the British East India Company and its
government enterprises
similarly coordinated military strategy.
[Music] The
American military-industrial complex followed suit and the Chinese
system does so today, making
the country the largest international  When you become a trading empire, your
transactions are paid in that country's currency, that currency
becomes the preferred global medium of exchange,
and that currency is so accepted and
used so often that people all over the world hoard it and it
becomes preferred.  It's a store of wealth and
therefore the world's main reserve currency.When the
Netherlands led world trade, the
guilder was the world's main reserve currency,
when Britain led, the pound sterling and the United States.
In the lead is the dollar.Naturally,
China's currency is increasingly being used as one of its reserve currencies.Having a
reserve currency allows its empire to
borrow more open funds than other countries.
The benefits are enormous.
Think about it. People all over the world
are willing to hoard their currency and put it back into their empires. Countries that don't have reserve currencies
don't have this, and their empires have their
own currencies.  You remember what happened in the United States
in 1971, when the
reserve currency of this empire runs out, it always asks for more money, and the extravagant privileges afforded by this imperial reserve currency
increase debt and start a financial bubble.
A series of causal relationships that linked mutual support to financial, political, and military power, supported by the weakening power of reserve currencies,
have been occurring together since recorded history began.
All of the world's most powerful empires  We've
followed this path to the top
[music]
p
b Since we've reached this point, these strengths have
endured, while embedded in the fruits of our success
are the seeds of decline.In principle, we
can say the following:  As people in more powerful countries
earn more, they become
more expensive and less competitive compared to people in other countries who are willing to work for less.
People in these countries naturally imitate the methods and techniques of major countries,
further reducing their competitiveness.
For example, workers in British shipyards
were cheaper than those in Dutch shipyards, so the UK
This gave the United States even more competitiveness,
which led to the rise of Britain and the decline of the Netherlands.
As we get richer, we
tend to work less hard; we enjoy vacations more; we
enjoy pursuing less sophisticated and less productive pursuits; and in
extreme cases we become decadent. Values ​​change from generation to generation from rise to top.
Perspectives
change: those who have bought wealth and power
and those who have inherited them;
those who have inherited them are unaccustomed to battle,
accustomed to luxury and easy living, and
are more vulnerable to chaos.  The
Golden Age in the Netherlands and the
Victorian Age in England are such periods of prosperity
[Music] As
people get used to things going well they become increasingly dependent on
good times to continue and to
continue this.
When money can be hunted, we are headed for a financial bubble.
Financial returns naturally dwindle and wealth inequality
widens. Wealth inequality is self-reinforcing
because
rich people use their wealth to leverage their
power.  They strengthen the system of values ​​between the rich haves and the poor have-nots by giving their
children greater privileges, such as
better education, and influencing political institutions in their own interests.  It
causes disparities in opportunities for political advancement. Less well-off
people perceive precision as unfair and
suffer more.
But as long as most people's living standards
rise, inequality and resentment will worsen and lead to conflict.
This will not lead to
excessive borrowing of the world's reserve currency, and
the country will
accumulate large amounts of debt from foreign countries.This
will increase spending power in the short term, but in the long term.
weakens a country's financial position.
[MUSIC] In other words, when
borrowing and spending are strong, an empire
looks very powerful,
but its finances are actually weak.
Borrowing is necessary to maintain an empire.  Sustaining a nation's power beyond its principles by financing
both domestic overconsumption and international military conflict will
inevitably make the costs of sustaining and defending an empire
greater than the revenues it brings.
For example, the Dutch Empire
expanded its reach around the world and waged
increasingly costly wars with Britain and other European powers to protect its territory and trade routes.The
British Empire also did the same.  Becoming large and bureaucratic, it
loses competitive advantages as rival powers, especially Germany, soar, leading to
costly cultural revolution competition and even global
competition.The United States has been at war with foreign countries since September 11th,
and  We're spending about $8 trillion on that,
and another $2 trillion on other military strategies and
maintaining military bases in 70 countries that
still support military competition with China in the region around China.
Countries that are weaker in this cycle
will eventually become indebted by borrowing from poorer countries that have the additional power of the rich countries.
This started in the 1908s when the United States
had a per capita income 40 times higher than China's and
began borrowing from
China because the dollar was the world's
reserve currency.
Similarly, the British Empire
borrowed large amounts of money from its poorer colonies, and the
Dutch did the same thing when they were at their peak,
as their empire grew stronger.  Then, in order to hold on to that currency, they
started selling it instead of accumulating it and collecting it, and the
power of the empire began to decline.  The
decline generally begins gradually
and then comes very suddenly. Economic
stagnation occurs when the debt becomes so large that the
empire can no longer
borrow the funds it needs to repay the debt.  The financial
bubble bursts
[Music]
This creates great turmoil within the country,
forcing Rick to choose between defaulting on his debts and printing lots of new money.
And ultimately, they
always choose to print more missions on a large scale,
which devalues ​​their currency and increases inflation.In
the case of the Netherlands, this meant fiscal provisions and
payments for the Anglo-Dutch War.
Similarly, in the UK it was the financial crisis caused by the
fiscal crisis and the payment of debts that emerged from the conflict between the two worlds,
and Beko writes that
from the 1990s onwards debt was
central in three cycles of boom and bust.  Banks are
taking stronger measures each time, and
if governments have trouble raising money for themselves, then there is a deterioration in the economic situation and a
decline in the standard of living for most people, and an astonishing rise in wealth,
values ​​and politics.  Inequality
intensifies infighting between the rich and the poor, and between different ethnic, religious and racial groups.This
leads to political extremism, manifested as populism on the right and the left, with
people on the left gaining access to wealth.  People on the redistribution right
seek to preserve wealth on the pillars of the
wealthy, typically at a time like this when
taxes on the wealthy go up and the
wealthy fear that their wealth and happiness will be taken away from them.
These drains reduce imperial revenues,
leading to a classic self-reinforcing hollowing out process: when the
drain on wealth becomes too severe, governments
outlaw it.
People seeking escape begin to panic.
Such turbulent conditions weaken productivity and lead to
conflicts over how to distribute the resources of a shrinking economic pie that has shrunk even further.  Populist
leaders come from both ends of the spectrum,
pledging to take control and restore order. This
is the moment of greatest challenge for democracy:
anarchy is out of control, and chaos is in the air.  Because that's
when transition is most likely. As
internal conflicts hatch and major changes are
needed, some
form of revolution or life breaks out for the redistribution of power.
This is Peace Falls.  In some cases, they maintained the existing order,
but in many cases they
were violent and therefore more orderly.
For example, Roosevelt redistributed wealth, while
others were relatively peaceful and maintained the existing domestic order. On the other
hand, the French Revolution  The Russian Revolution The Chinese Revolution was
much more violent, and it brought with it a new
domestic order, and
this internal conflict weakened the empire and led to a growing tendency for people to
see domestic weakness and take advantage of that challenge.  Becomes
vulnerable to the rise of rivals. This
increases the likelihood of major international conflict, especially if the empire is building an incoming military force. It also increases the likelihood of major international conflict
and the staggering military costs required to protect the empire from rivals.
This situation arises when internal
economic conditions are deteriorating and the empire is least able to afford military expenditures.The
lack of a viable system for peacefully arbitrating internal conflicts makes these conflicts difficult.  is
generally resolved as a test of strength. When a
bold challenge is posed, a great
power faces a difficult choice: fight or retreat. The
worst outcome is to fight and serve, but retreat.  This is not a good idea either, as it would give
in to rivals and
show the weakness of the empire to countries that were considering taking sides.
wars that inevitably lead to some form of war; wars are extremely expensive
; they also
cause behavioral transformations that readjust new orders to new realities of global wealth and power; and imperial preparations for the new realities of global wealth and power.  When
holders of currencies and debts become
distrustful and sell them, it
marks the end of the Big Cycle.
About 750 currencies have existed since 1700,
but less than 20% of them exist today, and
all have declined in value.
In other words, this happened after the defeat in the Fourth Anglo-Dutch War, when
the country was unable to
repay the huge debts it had built up during the war, and
this led to the
Bank of Amsterdam bank run.  This
led to desperate sales and forced the printing of huge amounts of banknotes, rendering the
existence of the empire meaningless. In
the case of good countries, this meant that even though they had won after World War II, they were
unable to raise funds for the war.
This happened when the United States was unable to repay the huge debts it had borrowed for the United States.This led to a series of
floral reprints, the devaluation and sale of the British pound,
while the United States and its dollar became dominant and
became the new world leader.
At the time of this recording, the United States has not yet reached that point,
with a debt greater than that of the Westerners, and with
more borrowing and more money printing, it
has become a marker.  The
debt burden has not yet begun. The
great civil strife and live conflicts that are all
happening for the typical reasons that lead to war have not
yet been surpassed,
even if in the end it is violent.
Regardless, as we emerge from these conflicts,
new winners emerge and work together to rebuild the losers' debts and
political institutions, establishing a new world order,
ending old cycles and empires, and
starting new ones all over again.  I've gone into
quite a bit of detail so far to give you an idea of ​​how a typical big cycle happens. Of course, not
all cycles occur exactly the same way, but
most of the time it's
true.  They are so similar
that their stories of rise and fall seem essentially the same,
and the only difference
is the way the characters dress and the technology they use.
So where are we headed
?  Music] It
's the future.
Most empires have periods of sunshine
and inevitable decline.
Reversing the vertebrae is difficult
because it requires undoing much that has already been done.
But it's possible.
By looking at these metrics, it's easy
to see where an empire is in the Big Cycle.
How healthy is it? Are things getting better
or worse? How many years has this been?
However, these estimates are not accurate,
and
cycles can be lengthened if those in the country pay attention to their vital signs and improve them.
For example,
If we know that a person is 60 years old, we can estimate how long that person will live based on how healthy they are,
whether they smoke, and a few other basic
vital signs.  It
may not be accurate, but it is a rough indicator and provides
clear direction on the steps to take to extend your lifespan.A
nation's biggest war is with itself.  It's often a war on
whether or not
we can make the tough decisions that will sustain our success. Ultimately, what we do
comes down to two things:
Make more money than we spend, and  Respecting and valuing each other,
solid education,
originality, competitiveness, and all the other things that I mentioned
are ways to achieve those two 10%.
It's easy,
so let's
do it like anyone who wants to be healthy and improve our vitals.Let's
do it individually and collectively.There are
some things we can do to better adapt to how the world moves.  I share these principles
because I want them
to help you recognize the situation we're in and the confusion we face,
and help you
make the decisions you need to navigate through these times.
[Music]
There's a lot more to talk about,
but time is running out, so if you're interested, you
can learn more in my book, Changing World Order.  I
look forward to continuing this dialogue.
Thank you for listening. May the
forces of evolution be together.
[Music]
Yeah
voodoo6 minutes